hello folks
and welcome to rational science
directly from frankfort germany
today i'm going to be talking about the
semi-circle
but before i get into the semicircle i
want to
touch upon a couple issues related to
extinction okay and when i start with
this
i'm going to show you a little picture a
little movie
an old movie and i want you to tell me
what you can imagine was different from
those days to
the days in which we live today and this
comes from the
end of the 19th century this is from
1897.
okay i want you to look at it and tell
me what's different between
what you see there and what you see
today okay here it goes the first one
okay
okay so take a good look
that was then okay
and the question is if you see
something all the things that you can
imagine
that were different okay from what we
have today
okay now here uh what
comes next is 10 years later okay and
the same thing the question is
what do you see that's different um
from what we have today okay all the
things that you can imagine
that you can see there that are
different or that you think
we're different uh those days to our
days
okay
nice pictures huh
okay hopefully uh you got some ideas
what was different then from what
it is today and i was focusing on
one specific thing and that's this one
that
there were no traffic lights in those
days okay
uh area we have from 1937
you know they just started putting some
of these traffic lights
out there they had the traffic lights
all the way
from 1914 and
you know they put some here and there in
the cities and some of the big cities
some of the big intersections
but it wasn't widespread in fact uh the
lights did not become
um popular until after world war
ii okay so that was like after 1945 you
had all these
other uh they were known as semaphores
on the street corners and only in a busy
streets okay
but there were other things that were
very different than today and here's a
same same test okay i want you to look
at this and tell me what you think
is different from today let's see if you
can pick up on it okay here it is
this was then in the old days
okay uh these this is in the 1930s and
the 40s
okay but here it starts okay this 19 to
100 to 1910 okay
these are the people in those days
1910-1920
even the kids okay
anything come to mind that was different
obviously different from what we have
today
okay well let me show you what we have
today
see if you can figure out immediately
what's different
this is today
yeah there was a time
that people didn't have what didn't wear
face masks
can you believe that yeah i know you
might think that i'm bluffing that i'm
leading you on but no there was a time
that people did not use
uh face mass and so
things change over time you know it's
like surrealistic that
we'd go back and find people without
face masks
okay some other things change um
one of the biggest changes in the 20th
century related to extinction again
uh is uh this country called
china okay and um
here's what it looked china looked like
in the
early century uh 20th century okay
these are 1910s 1920s it was a very
backward country
okay so uh
it had a lot of growth potential because
it was so backward
okay
and you can see how uh how people lived
in those days
and if you compared to today
here's a what china looks like today
some of the big cities
okay
changed quite a bit huh and most of that
change
in fact happened in the last uh few
years
what do you think of that big change in
china right
in fact uh one of the big worries today
especially of the western world is this
the fact that china is growing its
military
in fact it was uh quite popular these
days
on the news because there was a meeting
between
the people in the west the united states
and the people in the east the chinese
right
so there was a big talk about different
things
of mutual interest okay
and so this issue is
very irrelevant today china has grown
grown quite a bit and grown quite fast
i would i like to say that china is the
motor of the world uh in a sense that
it's thanks to china a lot of countries
are growing or still have growth because
they sell and buy
from china so there's still economic
activity
okay and you can see this in uh trend
here's a trend this is the gross
domestic
product for china in the last 10 years
you can see how it's growing
okay and uh is this uh
reason to be scared uh should be worried
should we be worried about this or
should we celebrate and say hey that's
great
you know uh chinese are becoming
richer uh compare that against the u.s
this is the u.s trend
it looks like it's going in the opposite
direction okay
um in fact it's had a couple
bad years uh what was it 2007 2008 and
then
uh 2020 that big
last one there okay so
the united states is not doing as well
as china apparently
okay again should you be
worried about that well some people
are here's an article that came out this
week and it triggered me to
look at this okay and that's a senator
from arkansas named tom cotton
he's a republican he's a um
you could say conservative uh right
wing et cetera et cetera okay
and the title of his article was what
the us must do to beat china
is this an issue we have to beat china
or something
east west versus west or is it maybe to
work together and come up
you know in parallel is there a way to
stop china
that's maybe a more fun
more fundamental question is there a way
to stop china
okay and um
here's uh what came out in one of the
articles
that followed up on this and then this
has to do with
the meeting that they had in alaska for
three days
chinese with their counterparts in the
u.s the state department
versus the ministry of
foreign relations in china it says the
biden administration has
cast the u.s china relationship as what
the biggest geopolitical test of the
21st century
right and lawmakers in both parties
agree
and are pushing the biden administration
to craft a comprehensive strategy to
counter
china's global rise
is it possible to counter
china's global rise or is this
inevitable
i mean china was so far back that
whatever new technology came to their
hands they
could you know suddenly leap
the great leap forward leap
hundreds of years you know kind of uh
you know they
they could jump or skip a lot of steps
that
other countries had to go through
because they just adapted the
technology implemented and suddenly you
know they're up in the air
they're uh much richer they can produce
more
they can sell more they're expanding
okay and so the question is is it
possible to stop
china from growing okay economically
and another question parallel to that is
do we want
to stop china from growing right money
is it possible
and the other one is it desirable okay
okay and it's better to look at this
graph it gives us a better picture of
what's going on in china
okay and i like this graph a little
better okay
and it shows that china's uh gdp
grew but it's been coming down now for
quite a few
15 years approximately it's coming down
okay and especially if uh other
countries don't grow
well uh china's not going to grow either
okay
and here's uh the u.s uh gdp
projection for the next 10 years and the
question is whether
uh these are just an extrapolation of
past trends
is this if this is real if this is
what's going to really happen
or is this just the fact that they're
extrapolating
you know trends for the sake of it
so so is this real
guess is that this is just an
extrapolation
they just well well there's this curve
and we're going to continue
you just saw the curve now last year
2020 gdp went down
and now it's going to continue in that
slanted curve upwards is that what we
can expect in the next 10 years
and my guess is not
for the united states or for china okay
i think china is also coming down in the
sense that
their gdp is gonna uh their growth rate
is gonna
diminish as time goes by and that means
that
curve is going to be asymptotic
the the gdp curve the total gdp
is going to be asymptotic uh china grew
because
it had a lot of growth in front of it a
lot of growth potential but
that potential is not now coming to an
end
there was a time china was growing at 25
in the i think in the 1990s 1995 in
thereabouts
uh they were growing 25 according to
some estimates
and now they're growing if they're lucky
and if they're not
lying on their uh numbers they're
growing only like six percent
okay so it's come down significantly
and that's because china's already quite
developed
compared to what it was the us cannot
grow at the same rate because the united
states is almost completely developed
there's not much more that the united
states can do
to grow you know at a rate like 25
no way you know it's already reached its
limit
and now china's kind of catching up and
that worries the people in the west
partly for military reasons but partly
because of you know the economic
influence that china is getting in the
world
okay okay
i bring this up because again i think
that
china at least for me right is a measure
or serves as a measure of how much time
we have on the clock
for extinction and it depends on
a lot on how much china grows
okay if china starts leveling off
we're all in trouble the united states
europe japan all the advanced
regions of the world are going to be in
big trouble
so let's hope that china doesn't level
off
but i think it's inevitable uh china
cannot grow at 25
now they're only growing at six percent
and at some point they're going to be
growing at
four three two and down the line
and when china grows at two percent it
means europe and the united states are
growing below
zero in other words they're gonna have
negative growth
or they're gonna approach zero at least
somewhere near zero
and that's gonna be a problem because
it's gonna be layoffs
and um and lots about people
people are gonna go out into the streets
burn cars you know
they're gonna protest there'll be lots
of parades
that's the way i see it at least okay
now um
a couple of gentlemen here uh put some
comments
related to the other day i said you know
anyone who's got a theory of extinction
that's different than mine mine says
that there's going to be an economic
collapse
and these people say no there ain't okay
so
what do they propose instead well they
don't propose anything instead
what they say is that essentially man is
going to live forever they can't see you
know as far as the eye can see
they cannot see how man will become
extinct anytime
say in the next century in other words
this entire century we're still going to
be here that's their version i guess
okay
and that's what they said okay this is
uh their comment
uh one file says bill's view of
extinction i refer the reader to the pdf
below which predicts our world
population
uh it provides various scenarios with
ranges from 2.3 billion to 36
billion with an average of blah blah
blah okay
and you talking about the year 2300
so he doesn't give me any uh theory of
extinction he just
puts out there what he reads this is
what he believes it
okay and he thinks uh there's nothing
that
you know it's gonna stop man from
continuing to grow to
to be alive at least for the next two
centuries at least
another fellow along the same lines as
population follows a
cycle linked to the sun
[Laughter]
okay as the climate warms population
goes up
yeah it's the heat right yeah as the
climate cools
as in now right the population goes down
okay and then he goes out and ran he
says the corrupt marxist
governments have destroyed the cities
and people are exiting uh
for the country okay so again israel
doesn't think that
um there's gonna be an extinction event
of man right uh all the animals all
around us are disappearing
uh our plants uh most of our plants that
we use because we re-breed them we a lot
of them we just
uh grow vegetatively in other words we
we they're seedless plants many of them
today are seedless plants a lot of them
have lost their genetic diversity
but we're going to be around for the
next million years according to these
folks because they cannot imagine
anything that could kill man
they cannot imagine anything that man
can't do and of course these people have
in the back of their minds that man is
not
part of the wild kingdom he's not part
of
the animal world or the mammal world
because
we have brains that's that's their
argument that's their entire argument so
we can think
i don't know maybe they're these two
vowels are an exception about
thinking you know but uh that's what
they have going through their minds that
we're not human because
well we're something else we're in other
words we're not animals we don't belong
to the animal kingdom where there's
plants there's rocks and then there's
mammals and other animals and then
there's humans that's the way they see
the world
they don't see us as being part
of the animal kingdom and that's why
they arrive at these conclusions they
think that because men can think he can
solve
all problems and again i keep saying
that when a brother's man can't
solve is having babies you know i said
that the other day i'm not going to go
through that again
but yeah we we cannot increase our
population even if we wanted to
you know even if we wanted to okay the
inversion
of the population pyramid human
population pyramid
is irrevocable whether we like it or not
some people say well we don't want to
have more children no no no
you can't even if you wanted to okay
and the economic um
reasons uh the main reason is you know
we went from the farms to the cities and
in the cities you have density dependent
birth rates
and because of that we simply cannot
with all our intelligence all our
foresight all our technology
there is nothing we can do to increase
uh population uh as we were in the past
you know
exponentially it's going to level off
and the question is you know what
happens after that
okay another thing we can't do anything
about is aging
but a lot of people think some how
they're going to invent some
technology out there that's gonna make
us live forever
which they don't even realize that
that's not desirable either i mean if we
live forever that's even gonna crowd out
even more the young people who come
behind so that guarantees extinction if
we live forever
so let's hope we don't you know come up
with that little idea there
okay um here's uh
one thing that this fellow can't with a
son he can't answer and that's
this curve there if uh if it's a
sudden type of issue you know that the
sun cycles make
people reproduce children you cannot
explain that curve
which is the one we've had for the last
almost 400 years
you know we uh expanded
population wise right exponentially in
the 19th century early 20th century and
now we're leveling off
and there's nothing we can do about that
as you can see the green line there
it shows that our growth rate population
growth rate
is going down and by mid-century it's
probably going to be
down to zero zero population growth as
it's called
even even if um
if uh things continue as normal as they
are now
remember these are just projections okay
doesn't mean that
this is gonna happen just means that
these are projections
uh more than likely that's going to
level off a lot sooner than
what people think okay
okay
one poll says i have uh three children
two
and i own 23 acres and grow my own food
i don't ask
anything of society but to leave us be
what ain't gonna happen i mean once the
uh once the world collapses the
global economy collapses they're gonna
run overrun your farm
and you it won't be 911 to call okay
so you won't be able to pick up the
phone and call 9-1-1 and say hey all
these guys are trespassing
no it's going to be like in the old days
you're going to be
you know you're going to plow by day and
defend whatever you plot or whatever
crops you
put out there by night okay
so no one's gonna protect you the big
problem after the whole world collapses
is protection no one will have
protection everybody is
on his own and of course uh
trust your neighbor at your own risk
some people say they're gonna
educate their neighbors to plant and to
grow
foods they're gonna show them how to do
it there's gonna be no time
you're just uh gonna have to fight off
everyone who comes into your uh
little garden and they're gonna
pick the garden clean and all you can do
is defend yourself
as best as you can someone's gonna
survive from that whole
mess it may not be you but even if it's
you you know i don't know if
you're going to survive for very long or
that you're going to reproduce the race
again
so yeah it's never going to happen
anyways
uh i always say that
anyone who wants to challenge the theory
has to do extinction 101 before he does
102.
everybody's an expert in extinction 102
which is human extinction
i have yet to find anyone who's an
expert on extinction 101 which is
mass extinction okay so uh
you know tell me how the animals in the
past died my theory is straightforward
my theory says they were all economic
collapses
all of them so the economy of the
dinosaurs fell apart the
the economy of the synapsids of the
amphibians
when their economy fell apart that's
when they became
extinct massively extinct what do i mean
by that i mean that you know
what an animal manages you know they
have economics as well
in the animal kingdom uh just like us no
different
it's that um you know their economy is
food and you know we think ours is
different
but no ours is also food the only reason
we produce all this other unnecessary
stuff
is to produce food ultimately to produce
food in other words you produce food to
live one more day to produce more things
uh that help you trade and
help you produce more food so that you
live one more day
that's how it works so the entire animal
kingdom
including mammals called humans
we all work for food ultimately
and what happened to these animals when
their food sources
disappeared that's when they disappeared
and after millions of years the
plants suffer their uh overturning of
their population pyramid
and the plants go away and when that
happens all the animals that forged the
relationship with those
plants for millions of years all those
families of
plants and all those families of animals
have fed on them
uh the whole thing collapses and that's
what happened at the end of the carbon
emphasis you know the permian and the
cretaceous and so on and so i have a
theory i'm saying that when there is no
food
you die now i think that's
straightforward doesn't mean you have to
believe in it
but you you should be able to understand
it unless you have a mental problem
okay i'm saying no food you die very
simple
and what the so-called paleontologists
have come up with in the last 200 years
is nonsense they think it's all due to
catastrophe
so you know hopefully you don't believe
in the same catastrophes don't put the
same nonsense
when you uh come and put a comment on
this you know uh
some people say that that first one
there that there was a
supernova one of the theories out there
another one says volcanic
activity another one says there was a
comet that hit the earth
or an asteroid and then uh you know
others say that there was a
quick climate change and that killed the
animals you know none of that nonsense
please
okay no you gotta have a you gotta
be a little more specific you gotta show
how uh climate change or
an asteroid kills some animals that left
the other ones alive
you know it's called cell activity with
food you can do that you know when food
chain collapses the other one continues
rolling
so food at least you can understand
whether you believe in it or not
that's the type of theory we're looking
for we're looking for a theory
that is full proof bulletproof
okay that even man can't do anything
about because if man's human economy
uh artificial economy collapses
no one produces food and so i think
that's a
pretty good theory
that you can at least understand whether
you believe in it or not
okay on with our semicircle before we
can get to the semi circle we got to
start
really at the circle because there were
lots of questions related to
the circle apparently people cling on to
the old days they were taught what a
circle is
in high school or college or wherever
maybe elementary school i don't know
and uh and they just parrot that they
just repeat it they don't even know what
they're saying
and so no one ever analyzed to see if
some of these geometries these figures
that we have in geometry or
make any sense they just accepted it and
now
i'm coming in here and saying those
definitions
are not wrong they're irrational
and they say oh no how can you say that
bill everybody believes in these
definitions
well i don't care if 100 of the planet
believes in them that doesn't make it
right i mean the whole planet can
believe in
the flat earth or in god for all we care
does that make god and the flat earth
right
or should we try to challenge that
theory and say well you know i don't
think that's
true i have a different way of looking
at things
and if there's something obviously wrong
patently wrong then
you got to modify whatever you learned
in high school in college or wherever
and that's the case with a circle not to
mention the semi-circle
okay so here it goes uh here's um
one and i'll just go with the questions
because essentially it's gonna be
question driven
they asked me so many questions this
week made so many comments that we might
as well just work with the comments
because
that's that's essentially what it's all
about okay here it is
here you have this phone he says uh
circle
as bill defines is not an object
well i define an object as that which
has shaped that circle there i think has
shape
so i don't know he's got to define what
he means by
object so that we know what he's talking
about but yeah i defined it as that
which has shape and there it is it has
shape so it meets the condition that
i'm having the definition the
specification that i put in there for
the word object
so i'm not sure what the problem is but
the the second one is funnier he says
the 2d
object is a concept so he does recognize
that that is
an object it's a two-dimensional object
there's three-dimensional objects and
two-dimensional objects
this is a two-dimensional what object
right that's what he said his own words
but he says it's a concept
so we have two dimensional concepts
there here here's uh you know
does energy have height and width does
the idea have height and width
right so i don't know uh
how you can have a two-dimensional
concept do concepts have
dimensions what's the uh
dimension what are the two dimensions or
the three dimensions
of uh mass for example how about that or
intelligence
how many dimensions does intelligence
have
apparently for this guy none you know
okay another comment or question related
to
the circle okay and it's
three gentlemen here put their notions
of what a circle is to them
how they learned it in high school in
college the first one says the
difference between a circle
and a disk because i showed this as a
disk
okay and i'm saying that this
is a circle that's a circle and they say
no that's a disk bill okay so what's a
circle
and so these people say the first one
says what is a continuous
line with nothing inside
the other is a filled circle
okay and both are 2d shapes
okay and the second file says a circle
is the set of points on a plane
equidistant from another point
okay that gold thing you're waving
around
is a disc okay another file says that
okay and then the third one says a
circle is a two-dimensional
shape whose center point is equidistant
from
any and every point on its perimeter
okay so we have a little difference
there between i don't know if you notice
the first one says it's a continuous
line that goes around
the other two say no it's a bunch of
points
so we already have a difference between
these gentlemen they probably
don't have the intelligence to realize
that they have a contradiction there
okay so i got to point that out to them
the two at the bottom say it's a bunch
of points that got in the top says it's
a continuous line that goes around
okay well the guy in the top is wrong
not irrational he's just wrong i mean
he's he never learned
apparently never took a course in
geometry because
first of all all lines in geometry are
made of points
from euclid even to the today all lines
are made of points
so he should have known that there is no
such thing as a continuous
line okay not in not even geometry
okay and the other reason is that um
you know um the line is really a
bunch of locations it's not even points
the famous word point means location
or number so we have a bunch of
locations
and a bunch of locations is motion so
uh they have locations they have motion
that's what
they're referring to when they say point
and so no it's not a continuous line
that's the first one and here we have um
proof of that evidence okay these guys
like proof and evidence here we have
we bring proof and evidence if i can get
this thing up there
oh where is it
there it is
let me put it over here maybe
okay here's uh circle okay
what was euclid's circle we talked about
the other day well it's a bunch of
it's a bunch of spokes that's what it is
a circle is a plane
figure okay uh contained by one line
such that
all the straight lines falling upon it
from one point among those lying within
the figure equal one another
well all each line according to euclid
ends in a point
in fact he's the definition of line that
he gives is that
a line has one point at each
end so the line that euclid
concocted is made of points and so those
lines
you have to think of them as made of
points and they end in a point that
means that the circle or the
circumference
as he called it is made of tiny
uh dots in other words what are those
dots
those dots are locations okay
and uh they're and they're not continued
so the line that's going around
is not uh really a solid line not a
continuous line
but if you have problems with that way
you still have good ol uh
stephen hawking and all the people today
this comes from
wolf wolfram uh mathworld
says a circle is what the set of points
these people should learn how to read
it's not a continuous
line it's a set of discrete points
in a plane what's a plane well hopefully
we'll find out in a second what a plane
is okay to make sure that we understand
whether
they're talking about just the points or
something
within the points okay
playing that are equidistant from a
given point zero
or o okay okay so uh it's a set of
points so it's not a continuous line
that's the first thing we got to clarify
here
and again it shows that you know
these fellows sometimes don't even study
geometry and they just
wing it they say well it's yeah it's a
continuous line no it's not
not according to mathematical physics
now i don't know where this gentleman
studied
maybe in the church i don't know
obviously he doesn't know something as
straightforward as that that there are
no lines that
are continuous they're all made of
points and second they're telling you
that it's
a bunch of points that you know are
somehow have
are equidistant from a center so we're
done there is
no such thing as a continuous line okay
and uh just in case uh we have a
clarification
from clark university the people who
have uh
put euclid's elements his book
online and they uh not only quote him
and put the translation but they also
analyze what
euclid attempted to say okay and uh this
is what euclid said
okay regarding or or the clarification
that clark
university uh does with us says
note that a circle for euclid right for
euclidean
is a two-dimensional figure two
dimensional figure okay so
really we're talking about a sheet
continuous sheet that's what a plane
is okay but in modern mathematics
usually the word circle refers to what
euclid calls what
the circumference of a circle
so euclid would not agree with the
circle that the mathematicians
that came after him concocted which is
this notion that
a circle is just a bunch of dots
uh at a certain distance from a center
that's not what euclid thought
he thought it was he was thinking of a
continuous line but then you know they
said well but the line is made of points
so uh euclid was contradicting himself
that's that's the bottom line but
anyways the notion that
euclid had is that the circle okay the
circle
is the whole thing the plane that goes
from
anything inside his continuous line
and that's not what these people are
saying these people are saying that the
circle is really what
the circumference they're saying that
circumference
and circle are synonyms that's what
they're saying okay
so let's get it right let's find out
what wolfram says here
wilkran says that they clarify what a
plane is
okay says um
a plane is a doubly ruled what
surface spanned by two
linearly independent vectors that means
it's a surface
which is spanned you know something is
stretching across that
surface that's what a plane
is and they say that circle is a plane
so these people are saying here wolfram
is saying that
a circle is not the little dotted thing
you know the the little wheel the just
the outside of the
circle the circumference now they're
saying it's the plane it's what's within
the uh these dots that
region is what the circle is because a
plane is a two-dimensional
surface and uh so we have to keep
looking at these definitions what is a
two-dimensional sub-manifold because
that's the word they're going to use
it's um i'm sorry
it says two-dimensional sub-manifold of
three-dimensional euclidean space okay
what's a manifold a topological space
that is
locally euclidean meaning that if you go
sufficiently close to the thing it's
almost flat
what is flat a surface okay and
again a topological space is a set of x
together with a collection of open
subsets blah blah
blah blah blah what are they talking
about numbers
right you can look up each one of these
definitions you'll find that
they're not talking about physics
they're talking about math
and math and physics will never meet
math is math physics is physic the twain
shall never mean
and uh this is the problem the problem
is that these people try to
turn physics or mathematize physics
that's what they try to do
since the days of euclid but the
important thing is that what is a plane
okay a plane is a surface it's a
continuous surface that's the notion
and they say that a circle belongs to
planes therefore it cannot be just a
dotted perimeter
okay i want to make sure that those
points are are clear okay okay
but uh when all else fails this is what
you gotta answer
if this is a circumference bunch of dots
going around right and that is a disc
according to some of these people
then what in the world is a circle
i mean if either the circle is a synonym
of circumference or the circle is a
synonym of desk
what other option is there which one do
you want
sometimes they say it's a plane meaning
they're referring to the disk
and other times they say no it's just
the little dots on the outside than the
perimeter
in which case they're talking about the
circumference what do we need the word
circle for
if we have the word circumference for
one and we have the word disc for the
other
okay so this is where we're at it is an
irrational definition what they have for
the word
circle it's an irrational definition
because they can't make up their minds
whether the circle
is uh just the
dotted perimeter or whether it is the
disc
itself and they do have to clarify that
i mean
if we're going to use these definitions
consistently if we're going to apply
them
to geometry then they should tell us you
know
whoever is going to give the
presentation right the geometer or
whatever
he's got to tell us which which he calls
the circle
is it the circumference or is it the
uh disc and as of today we have no
answer to that question
they want both as always they have all
these dualities in mathematics
okay so let's go on with the
uh oh well there's uh there's also to
confuse things even further
it's not only those dots that are out
there just static there
it's also that a circle is something
that's
twirling around it's the famous
figure of mathematics is
a dot that's moving around in circles
okay so if you
roll an apple at the end of a string
they call that a circle
okay it says equivalently this is out of
the wikipedia says
it is the curve traced out by a point
that moves
so they have what is known as a dynamic
figure
that's the other version of the circle
of mathematics so they have both they
have
one where all these dots are just out
there and the other one where it's an
apple going around in circles
right okay and
so here we see other people trying to
define or give us their notion of what a
circle is
one file says a set radius swiped around
the reference point
restricted to a plane a circle can be
drawn
well again it's as similar as with the
one on the left
because what the fellow says is uh this
is how you draw a circle
so who cares i want to know what a
circle is before you draw it what do you
mean by circle
i mean if you're going to define it
otherwise you know finish the circle and
call me when you're finished drawing it
but this person's just telling you you
know how to how to
draw a circle another fellow just gives
you an equation he said this is a circle
and he gives you some kind of equation
there's another who also gives you an
equation but
see the interesting thing about that
other equation the one that's got the
powers powers of two right
uh squared uh it means they're talking
about a surface they're talking about
if that's a circle then they're talking
about again a plane they're talking
about
uh they're saying the circle is the
whole thing
that's within the perimeter of those
dots
and then a third guy says circumference
and i guess he copied this from the wiki
also because i saw the same thing there
it says circumference
in geometry a plane curve plane
plane you mean like plane you like
surface you mean like a sheet continuous
sheet
is that what a plane is plane curve the
locus of points equidistant from a fixed
point
c called the center of the circumference
again you know uh so is is the
circumference the same
thing as the circle and then
he continues as the circle is the flat
what
surface enclosed by a circumference
and again we have a problem because we
don't know whether the uh
circle is the circumference or circle is
the disc
and until this foul can
tell us that he can't give his
presentation we need to know what he
means by the word circle
and right now everybody's confusing
circle with circumference in one
instance and circle with disk on the
other
okay so once again i repeat
this is a circle
we point to it and say circle okay now
this one is a 3d
i use it for representations only
you can only put a circle on paper and
it's got to be
final it's got to be there already i
can't say let me draw it for you no no i
don't care
call me when you're finished drawing it
and then uh
you got to describe what you you drew
and if you're going to say that
it's just a circumference and that the
circumference is a
solid line when all lines in
mathematical physics are made of points
discrete points
which are not points which are locations
which are really numbers
uh you know ordered pairs that's what
they are
so what the hell are we talking about
after a while you know we don't we have
no idea
okay because the fellow has to tell us
what he means by circle
and one of the problems there is people
say well bill
what use do we have for this for for
this disc
your famous disc we don't care
we don't care what use you have for it
here we're trying to find out what a
circle
is this is what a circle is
okay and if people don't like this then
they have to tell us what a circle is
and if they're gonna define it it's not
a figure because in science we do not
define
objects figures things in science we
point to them
okay so you point to a circle okay if
you're going to define it then you're
talking about a concept
and concepts are not figures that means
it doesn't belong in geometry to begin
with
yeah we don't have com concepts that are
figures
now it's either a figure it's or it's a
concept and if you define it it's a
concept
it's that simple okay so uh what is a
semicircle let's find out well here it
is
okay it's a half a circle this is
euclid's version
okay it's in his definition 18
okay in book number one of elements
so the semi-circle is the figure uh
contained by the diameter
and the circumference cut off by it
okay so that's euclid's version against
he made his circle with lines
there's always a line between any two
lines so his circle
is never finished it's known as the
unfinished circle
okay and he says it's a continuous line
that
covers that circumference he's wrong
there too because
all lines are made of points discrete
points that means between any two points
you can fit another one according to
euclid and according to math today as
well so
so the whole definition is screwed up
it's no good whatsoever it's
irrational okay and the center of the
semicircle is the same as that of the
circle
great okay that's euclid's version uh
this is the one from uh
mathematical physics today this is
today's version
maybe i should put it over here
next to euclid's famous semicircle
half a circle that's what wolfram calls
it that's what a semi-circle is
the area and it could continue says the
area of a semi-circle of radius r
is given by blah blah blah blah blah
area what do you mean
area of a sermon circle i thought a
semi-circle was just those dotted lines
why are you talking about area of a semi
circle so we have a problem
because uh now suddenly he swit they
define it as a bunch of points but then
when they talk about
area they talk about the area of the
circle
and they're referring to the circle
itself what's on the inside of the
dots within the dots within the
perimeter
and you see this when you look at the
word cylinder also
from wolfram uh a solid of circular
cross
section in which the centers of what of
the
circles all lie on a single line
what is a circle according to the
cylinder version well it's a cross
section a slice of a cylinder and that
means they're talking about not just the
outer
rim they're talking about the area
within
the rim as well they're talking about
that surface that's what a plane
is okay so so these people have to make
up their mind they can't keep going back
and forth and saying
you know this is what a circle is and
then they don't use that notion of a
circle
because they're going to be using this
notion the slice the
cross section right
so this is where we have a problem with
all these people because
they're not using their def they define
one thing then they don't use it they
say well we're going to take a slice of
a cylinder and we're going to call that
a circle
that's not how you defined it you define
it as a bunch of points
what's this nonsense about now saying
that it's a slice
it's a continuous surface
from perimeter to perimeter from one
side of the perimeter to the other side
of the perimeter
which is it and of course they can't
answer
that question because they say it's both
or none
depending on whether they want to
overrule you they say well it's none you
know so
don't attack us okay so here's a little
summary
of the circle from my point of view okay
mathematical physics is the vain
attempt to merge mathematics and physics
this started with at least with the
greeks not earlier
why because they had a surface or they
had some some
object out there some figure could have
been a cube also a solid
and they immediately tried to
measure and look at the relationships
between measurements that's how this
grew that's how geometry
was born so here they had a figure
which belonged to physics and what they
did was they brought math
measurement units numbers
they looked at relations and all that
belongs to math it doesn't belong to
physics
at all and you cannot have physics and
math and math and physics
never the twin shall meet okay and this
is where the problem is that's how we
ended up with a religion
of mathematical physics today and that's
why we have all this nonsense out there
like black holes and dark matter and
dark energy
and particles at two places at once
because it's a vain attempt to merge
mathematics with physics no math is not
the language of physics the language of
physics
is illustration in the religion of math
fizz right a line is made of infinite
points
that's according to their own rules this
is not me putting words in their mouth
this is according to the horse's mouth
they themselves say that a line is made
of points
that's never changed since the days of
euclid in fact if you look at aristotle
he said the same thing i covered that in
the past
as well they talk about motion uh
they for every location they call that a
dot or they put a dot and they call it a
point
and what does that point represent a
location what are they talking about
they're talking about
motion and that's what a line is that's
why they talk about
one dimensional line what do you mean
one dimensional line what kind of
figure geometric figure is that
no such monster you cannot even imagine
a one-dimensional line
why because they're not talking about
dimensions they're not talking about
lines figures they're talking about
motion mathematics has no use for lines
mathematics has no use for dots
mathematic
mathematics has no use for planes or
solids
is a solid um hollow
a cube when they say cube or you think
it's a hollow cube
or why do we call it solid it's solid
right
yeah these people want to make you think
that it's just a perimeter the outside
of it the surface or whatever
okay in physics no object is infinite
okay maybe in in the religion of math uh
uh object is infinite but not in science
and all objects are finite by definition
what is an object that which has shape
hopefully all shapes end somewhere okay
so they're all finite
in physics the amount of matter in
existence is finite
okay god does not create
matter every day we cannot turn space
into atoms and atoms into space no
way in either direction and so the
amount of matter
in existence out there you know wherever
you go in the universe
the amount of matter is constant okay
neither though sorry
in the religion of mathematical physics
a point is
misleading is a misleading term that
means neither
it means either location or
number that's what the word point means
so they use the word point because they
want to incorporate both notions
uh location which is a concept
of physics we talk about the location of
objects okay
and has nothing to do you know the
qualitative qualitative notion of
location has nothing at all to do with
math math has no use for the qualitative
notion
of location that's why they don't use
the word location
they always talk about position and what
is position
well it's an ordered pair an ordered
triplet or whatever
it's a bunch of numbers that's what a
position is to a mathematician
it's got nothing to do with you having
distance with respect to mean
that's why they never were able to
define what location is they don't have
a use for
for such a word and they don't have a
use for the word motion
either they use displacement or you know
something along those lines
they're not going to use the word motion
meaning
qualitative motion because they have no
use for that just like they have no use
for the
qualitative time they only have used for
quantitative time they have to use
seconds and minutes and years and
whatever
they have no use for saying uh before
and after
math has no use with those type of
notions those concepts
yeah neither location nor number
is a figure so if uh
a point is location if a point is
number well then they're not talking
about geometry because geometry
first and foremost is what the uh study
or the analysis of shapes so you have to
have a shape
and if they're going to start with a
point which is the
building block of geometry and they say
well what is the point well it's zero
dimensional
that which has no part euclid said
meaning there's nothing there
because he was referring to location not
to a geometric
figure okay so yeah we have a problem
already starting point there are no
such things as zero dimensional points
or one dimensional lines in
physics maybe in the religion of math
you know math is
and then the line of math is is an
itinerary
okay it's made of points the point is
location so we're talking about
itineraries
and of course when you raise these
issues with
uh these folks uh they don't like uh to
hear that because
this is what they studied in school in
high school and college
and so they said are you telling us that
for two thousand five hundred or three
thousand years we've been wrong uh
no you've been irrational and if it's
irrational you have to challenge it not
accept it on the basis of authority
these people are accepting all this
stuff on the basis of authority
and tradition they say well this is how
i learned in school and this is what
everybody out there believes in and
that's what i'm going to use
yeah go ahead and use it i'm just
telling you it's irrational because the
definitions
are irrational they're they contradict
each other we don't know what a circle
is
and when i challenge these people they
all the only argument they have is
authority and tradition
that's it they have no other argument
they cannot challenge what i'm saying
because i'm saying something that is
straightforward i'm showing that
according to the definitions of
mathematical physics
according to the definitions of geometry
itself
they have contradictions here and if
they have contradiction they have
irrationality you can't use those
notions consistently and they can then
they don't
they don't use them consistently they
just switch over whichever one they need
whenever they need the
for the circle at least you know
whenever they need the perimeter they
use the perimeter they
call circumference circle whatever they
could call whatever they could call it x
and whenever they need to this they say
circle disk or whatever they need
to call it again they can call it y for
all we care
we have a contradiction and so we don't
have a circle
and if a semi circle is half of a circle
and the circle is already irrational
well we have a an irrational semi-circle
as well
okay just uh maybe some a coral area
here
uh if i get it in there
it's all the way at the bottom let's get
a little corollary here
put it on this side okay what's the
coral area the corollary is that
the circle of math is not a continuous
curved line
okay because all lines are made of
points
dots meaning locations meaning numbers
ordered pairs so if you're talking about
2d right
and so uh the circle of mathematics is
not a continuous line that's the first
one i want to
challenge okay so anyone who thinks that
is fighting the establishment not me
okay it's made of discrete points that's
the first thing you have to understand
you haven't learned that well you
haven't taken your first course in
geometry
okay in school mathematics there are
gazillions of points between
any two points okay that's the
worldly wisdom in geometry in
mathematical physics so
first learn the basics okay the circle
of mathematics is not a plane
okay because uh they say it's just uh
a bunch of dots that form a perimeter
and then you know they always talk about
surface and they always talk about area
so you say well what do you mean it's
not a plane
uh you know is it a plane or is it not a
plane if it is a plane uh
then then the whole disc is a circle
this is a circle okay and uh
and if you're if you're just going to
talk about a perimeter then you're not
talking about a plane
that's not a plane okay a bunch of dots
is not a plane
okay um what is it's a ring made of
discrete
points which are not in touch with each
other okay so there's holes
everywhere between any two dots in the
perimeter
the water is leaking out through all of
them and you can plug it with more
points just put as many points as you
want i'll put another one in between any
of your two points
so you can't plug uh
the perimeter of your so-called circle
okay
it's not a hula hoop made of a single
piece no it's got all these little dots
okay
that form the circle and then uh
concepts we define so if they're gonna
define a circle it's a concept and no
then it doesn't belong to geometry it's
not a figure figures
objects we point to
okay let's get on with the questions for
this week
and comments one fellow says
[Music]
so as if we currently see things as were
as
where they were when uh then does that
mean location is not instantaneous
because you got to think location is
always live
since the ropes are straight and not
curving in
uh on an angle from uh
a things from a thing's old position
um yeah we have to distinguish between
location
which is instantaneous in other words
location is a static concept the other
one is
measurement or what the observer sees
and that
is not necessarily where the object was
okay because it takes time takes motion
for the torsion along the rope to arrive
to your eyes you know you look at the
andromeda galaxy
light only travels at 300 000 kilometers
per second no
no no uh slower and no faster
always at a constant speed okay
why because the only thing that changes
if we follow the little c
equals frequency times wavelength it's
little c being a
constant it's called a constant and a
constant is what
300 000 kilometers per second plus or
minus right
and that's the speed of light always
travels at the same speed the only thing
that changes is frequency
with wavelength so if light always
travels at little c
and something is very far away like the
andromeda galaxy yeah it's going to take
some time to
reach your eyes that doesn't mean that
when that thing blips in your
the atoms of your eye and allow you to
see
the andromeda galaxy which is 2.2
million
light years away meaning traveling at
the speed of light it takes 2.2 million
years for that light to reach your eye
then yes you are
looking at andromeda when it was in the
past
and that's essentially what einstein
said and he
have to put my hand in the fire for that
one for him okay
and uh yeah it travels at a constant
speed
and it takes time okay so you get to
distinguish between location and what
the observer perceives
okay so that's my comment there next
issue fellow says
uh zero time is t equals zero
[Laughter]
t equals zero and delta t equals zero
have different meanings
okay i don't know if that makes
any important if that's important at all
i think that instantaneous means the
limit of delta t
tending to zero no instantaneous is not
the limit that's what they
keep telling people who study math okay
you you know when you go to cars they
teach you about the limits
okay and that's not what it is
uh and again he says infinitesimal in
mathematical terms
now we don't care about that uh
instantaneous
means a single frame of the film that's
what instantaneous means
there's no such thing as instantaneous
motion let alone
instantaneous time so t 0 belongs
exclusively to the religion of
mathematics there's no such thing as t
equals zero in science
okay uh there's either before and after
uh so whenever you get stuck with math
and you don't understand it because math
gets in your way well just turn it into
qualitative stuff
and then you'll understand it uh time is
before
and after yesterday and today or
tomorrow or whatever
uh there's got to be two frames in the
film okay and so
um t equals zero
really is equal to location means no
motion no time okay and there it is
uh for the purposes of mathematics it's
just the beginning of your number line
that's
it the starting point what's at that
point location
only because you have t equals zero
there's been no motion no time
okay so i don't know why this is so hard
for some people to
to understand instantaneous means a
single
frame in the movie there's no motion no
time
i don't know how else to say that if you
don't understand that well then you have
a
little bit of a problem you don't have
to see uh
a physicist what you need is a
psychiatrist
okay hopefully people understand t
equals zero is equal to
instantaneous which means no motion
that's what instantaneous means
no such monsters instantaneous
motion like in mathematical physics they
have t equals zero
okay uh phil says the assistant will
have to say when he felt the
perturbation
with his hands holding the rope on the
other end i was talking about separating
the
ends of one rope so that you could
compare
the sep the speed of separation versus
the speed
of the torsion along the rope and
the first comment there is that there
are no observers in science so we don't
have
uh uh we're not talking about what the
assistant uh sensed okay
that's why i'm saying just tie it to the
wall tie your rope to the wall
open uh the other end
and film it and then just look
objectively
at the film okay and see if the speed
here is the same as the speed there
okay and there uh the next comment he
put in there says
this proposed mechanism of yours leads
us to say that the rope is not rigid
yeah the rope is not rigid because
i don't know where you got that word we
never use the word rigid for the rope
the rope is really taut it's
pulled tightly that's not the same thing
as rigid rigid means made of a single
piece
which is what he analyzes here and so
the mathematical experiment only
purports to compare the speed of
propagation of a torsion
along a rope with the speed of quantum
jumping
so we have this you know the
atom is expanding and contracting and
that expansion contracting is what
uh torques the rope and then the torsion
along the rope is much
faster because it reaches a farther
distance than the distance
in the separate in the atom just
expanding and contracting
and so i put as an example as an analogy
a gun pulling the trigger on the gun
is not the same speed as the bullet
leaving and you know shooting outwards
the bullet goes a little faster than the
finger on the gun
on the trigger okay and that's more or
less the
analogy for an atom an atom the pumping
of an atom
is not nearly as fast as the torsion
along the rope and again
you know i don't know how else to put
that to people
hopefully they understand
my god sometimes okay uh let's continue
here we have
another fella or i think it's saint paul
bill let's start defining the word tree
because it doesn't have a unique meaning
as you think and he goes into
defining the word tree as well as
confusing
the word tree when you when you look at
just one tree and you point to it and
say
tree it could be a sycamore tree could
be a fig tree we don't care what tree it
is or
gazillions of trees out there
tree is a category of plants
as a category it's not an object we're
talking about when
when you point to a tree that's that's
the object
okay so please do not confuse the
category
with what you're pointing to my god
these people have really mental problems
i have to believe these people you know
really have to see a psychiatrist
they can't tell the difference between a
category
and and the thing you're pointing to
it's it's just mind-blowing unbelievable
sometimes
okay another fellow he goes in there he
says what
there's a huge difference of an image on
a screen
yeah image on the screen is an object
that does not exist
okay doesn't exist the object does not
exist
versus a tree we can see and touch that
has 3d properties in a 3d locational
environment which has
weight yeah that's an object that exists
so what is an object that does not exist
a 2d
image on a screen or a piece of paper or
the one you're imagining
okay you know that tree that rock that
you were thinking of
that's a rock and the word rock refers
to an object and you say but that's the
one that i imagine
yeah it's still an object you know when
you say
rock we all imagine some kind of stone
out there you know something
uh something it's got uh
you know when ernie once mentions the
word rock well this guy imagines one
type of rock maybe it's yellow the other
guy
imagines a gray rock the other one a
blue one who knows a brown one
we all imagine our rocks different
shapes different colors when someone
mentions the word rock but everybody
imagines a shape when the guy says rock
you know what are you thinking of when
the guy says rock he says think of a
rock
what are you going to think of well you
got to think of a rock you know it's got
to have shape
and if it has shape it's an object and
the word rock always refers to an object
the one you point to not
the category of rocks like this follow
here okay
so he says what is an object yeah that
exists and what is a 2d
object that does not exist i filled in
the blanks therefore
okay so are you defining existence or
object what do you want to talk about
you want to talk about exist
or you want to talk about object make up
your mind
because this guy is distinguishing
between what exists and what doesn't
exist he's not
telling me anything about the word
object he's just saying that this
these objects exist and these other ones
donate these other
objects don't exist that's all he said
he hasn't said anything about the word
object
he's got to define the word object and
he's got to do so in a way that he can
use it consistently
in other words a lot of these people go
out there and they look for a definition
they put it in there they don't even
analyze it
they don't even know what they wrote
they have to take a reading
comprehension
course because they don't know what they
read they just copy and paste
there it is and so the guy doesn't know
what he what he put in there he doesn't
know what he
what what he's defending what he's
attacking because
this guy's attacking the word exist not
the word object we're talking about the
word
object what is an object for the
purposes of physics
and an object is that which has shape
and
physics only deals with objects that
exist
not with with objects that do not exist
that doesn't mean they're not objects
because they don't exist
okay okay another fellow
and he says the following he says
uh one thing you can define with
complete negation
is no thing the absence of all things
and i guess something is no
nothing no nothing
right is that what what he means we're
just gonna put uh negations you know a
horse is a
what is a horse well a horse is a not a
dog and not a cat
uh not an elephant it's not a tree not
are we gonna put all the knots that are
horses is that
a definition of a horse is that how
you're going to define it
okay so uh so what is energy well it's
not intelligence it's not
uh mass it's not force we're going to go
through all the words that it's not
is this a guessing game now you can't
use
uh negations because negations are
synonyms
turned around they turned into antonyms
and this fellow believes that because
he's got an antonym
that he defined the term the answer is
no
an antonym is no definition at all
so uh no nothing is not
a no thing because then a thing is a
no no thing no nothing
okay next one my god some of these
people
here's a file says
upon the other side give me a second
here
all the way down at the bottom okay
file says describing flat as
lack of thickness is wrong
wrong according to whose religion yours
some thing has thickness
well in order to understand what you're
saying or find out if it's wrong or
right uh
be nice if you define what a thing is
in what way do you define the word thing
in such a way that it includes thickness
and that you can use that
definition consistently
and so no uh things do not
have thickness okay things have shape
that's the only universal property of
things some things
have thickness some things have weight
some things are 3d
we have all kinds of or types of things
okay so no a thing is not that which has
thickness
a thing is not that which has weight
anything
is not that which moves has mass
energy or any of those things that
mathematical physics has invented
okay here's another issue another
question
says why is there movement at all
totally irrational question okay so
anyone who asks that question is like
asking
why are they objects why are there
objects
and the answer is that's an irrational
question
because you're introducing a question of
philosophy
which answers questions of purpose
and reason and you're phrasing it in the
context of physics
which deals with objects causes and
mechanisms
so the answer to why is there moving at
all the answer is always the same
because god wanted it that way okay
that's why there is movement
god said everything in motion he's the
guy who created everything
so why are there objects because god had
a headache
and why is there movement well because
god took an aspirin a headache went away
that's why the why
questions have to do with philosophy
in this context when you're talking
about reason and purpose you're talking
about philosophy not about physics
that's why it's an irrational question
okay okay next one
fellow says the most
accurate what descriptive
model in is the quantum model
whoa is is that what science is about
is that what physics is about describing
i describe a chair
and that's science that's
physics you know here uh i
measure this chair it has one seat two
armrests and four legs
does that make you a scientist that that
make you a physicist because you
described
a chair so this person
thinks that quantum is the most accurate
scientific or physical theory because it
describes
no descriptions are not part of science
science we don't describe the science we
have to explain
you gotta explain something okay okay
and uh ah so on the other side again
a second here
another issue or comment on this i know
i just wanted to
say here that there's this professor's
donald simonet he's from uh
with lockhaven university in
pennsylvania
uh emeritus by the way and uh he says
science doesn't explain
science describes and that's what most
people out there believe
and the reason they believe that is that
mathematics can only describe
and so for the last 400 years we have
equated science
with math when that's not the case
meaning math you know science meaning
physics right
so they're equating physics with math
when physics has absolutely
nothing to do with math mathematics has
nothing to do with physics
mathematics is just a descriptive
language
that's all it is it just describes and
science is not about describing neither
is physics physics is about explaining
you have to explain something
otherwise if you describe a chair is
that science is that what
quantum does just describe you know so
no
uh science is not about describing
science is about explaining because
that's where you have to break your
brains
that's where you gotta you know burn
some calories up to some great matter
okay and um
just in case for those who are wondering
here's the difference between an
explanation and a description
okay explain uh the causes
or reasons in the case of philosophy
underlying a phenomenon
okay and uh second
notion of that is how or why a
consummated event happened an
explanation deals exclusively with the
past
science only deals with the past we have
to explain consummated events we have to
explain
how something happened you know what
caused it to happen
that's the issue how a magnet attracts
another okay
so when you say why does a magnet
attract another you're really saying
how what caused it okay
that's what physics is about not saying
it did
that's not science that's description
that's mathematics
okay and then they give an irrational
explanation
for why it did or how it did it yeah
so and what is the description it's just
a listing of properties of the physical
object
in science we use adjectives to describe
and adverbs when we want to qualify or
characterize
motion okay
next issue uh file says
get it up here gotta get faster at
raising these things up there it quantum
mechanics has many flaws
in its physical interpretation
acknowledged by
physicists despite what bill says
well this fellow is putting words in my
mouth okay
uh i've always said
and here's proof evidence yeah
okay here's uh what i always put up
there
fine man i think i can safely say that
nobody understands quantum mechanics
niels bohr said it uh
steven weinberg nobel prize he said it
werner heisenberg they all said the same
thing no one
understands quantum mechanics
and so i'm repeating what they're saying
when i say this
people like this gentleman here they say
well you didn't understand really what
what they meant by that
i didn't understand what they meant by
that they're saying that they don't
understand
all of them saying and these people say
well if they didn't understand
how can we have technology that's
essentially their answer most of the
times okay they say
they do understand for otherwise you
wouldn't have that computer you're
typing on
that's the kind of answer they give you
okay so uh
here are the issues okay
for this gentleman to answer okay if
he's smart enough which
i doubt okay these are the issues he's
gonna answer
okay first of all he's using this the
statement let's put that up there again
so we can compare it okay
get rid of feynman here
there we go see get rid of that he said
has many flaws why does he use that
language
it's not that it has many flaws okay
buddy
it's that there is not a single rational
def um explanation a single rational
physical interpretation in all of
mathematical physics in
all of quantum mechanics why does he
says it has
many flaws it doesn't have many flaws
there's not
one physical interpretation that is
rational in
all of mathematical physics and that's
what i challenge this fellow to come up
with just one
explanation that is rational okay by
rational i mean that you can make a
movie of it and you can understand it
by moving by simply staring at the movie
okay
and so here are the uh issues because
these
people when you say hey you know uh here
you have
financing that you know no one
understands quantum mechanics
they say of course they understand for
otherwise you wouldn't have a computer
you're typing on that's the kind of
answer they give you
so here's the issue to you okay do the
mathematicians
understand or don't they can they give
you a physical interpretation for the
sub-atomic world or not
can they draw a hydrogen atom okay and
justify it i mean you know does the
electron bead
how does it stand uh always in an orbit
why does it
fly away spontaneously why does it fall
to the nucleus
that's what you got to explain so it's
not just saying yeah i can draw a
hydrogen atom
yeah some idiocy that you might draw
that doesn't mean that you can justify
it
in fact they explain electricity with
the
planetary model they explain what is a
quantum jump with a planetary model they
explain ionization with a planetary
model
so please justify the the planetary
model
that's what you got to justify what you
got to justify why
why doesn't the electron fall to the
center to the nucleus or why does it
spontaneously fly away
if you can't answer that question you
don't have a rational hydrogen atom and
you can't even start your presentation
can anyone in in mathematical physics in
mathematics can they make sense of a
particle being a two places at once
what sense does that make that came from
the mind of an idiot
that's what it's known it's an idiot
that's the correct word don't tell me
that it has many flaws
tell them that they're all a bunch of
idiots that's the correct language to
use
i'm being polite here i'm just calling
them idiots
okay does the fact that we have
computers prove that a particle can be
in two places at once
okay that's the theory that these people
are giving you
so don't tell me it has many flaws it's
all flawed and it's not flawed it is
irrational that's what it's called
and and this uh wishy-washy guy who
gives us the answer he says
has many flaws in that physical
interpretation
why does he use the correct language and
say it's all irrational
because otherwise his religion goes down
the drain that's why he's not willing to
say that
so he said well let's get some flaws we
have to work on it still
there's nothing to work on it they're
never going to work on it
they're not no one's working on it
because they can't work on you cannot
explain
absolutely anything anything with
particles
and quantum is based on particles so
every time you introduce the particle
hypothesis meaning
which by the way is not a particle but
that's a second issue
but even if you did it with with
corpuscles with classical particles
you cannot explain a single phenomenon
in quantum mechanics
in in the subatomic world not one
listen what i'm saying i want you to
explain one
find anything anywhere anywhere on the
planet any any
mathematical physics then can explain
one
just one uh can give you a physical
interpretation
that is rational i mean entanglement
action at a distance how does this
particle affect that one uh
tunneling how does this particle uh go
through the barrier and appear on the
other side it's all magic
it's more than magic it's unimaginable
you know particle at two places at once
what's there to imagine how how is that
possible what sense does it make
so the correct word is idiot that's the
word you gotta use when you refer to a
mathematician
mathematician you gotta use the word
idiot you gotta call him an idiot then
you're okay
and you're fine don't say he's got flaws
and that he's working on and we don't
know everything that's idiocy
okay another issue
okay uh if i can get this thing in there
okay another perhaps one day we'll find
the true physical
interpretations that underlie our
universe but for now it's exciting to
experimentally
verify and science we don't verify
anything
but uh she says sunday some have happy
day right
i'm gonna do it by myself that's how the
song went right
well here it is okay here's my answer to
this fellow
um what will change in the next
400 years that hasn't changed in the
last 400 years
if the mathematicians right continue to
be in charge of science
what are they going to do just
descriptions for the next 400 years
assuming we live that long
how can a mathematician ever provide a
rational physical interpretation to a
mechanism
if he doesn't introduce objects because
he
wants to mathematize everything he just
talks about equations
only does equations and dismisses
physical interpretations as philosophy
oh that's philosophy we know it's
irrational
so they know it's irrational they can't
give you a physical interpretation they
don't use
objects but you want them to give you a
physical interpretation someday
some have happy day experimental verify
that's known as religion that's only
goes to
believing to your opinion to change your
opinion or to confirm your opinion
so anything related to the word verify
religion
has nothing to do with science
whatsoever we don't verify anything
certainly we don't use experiments in
science
the only purpose of an experiment is to
persuade the jury the only purpose of
evidence is to persuade the jury
okay so verify you know they have those
synonyms or
or what it means very belief opinion
experiment proof
persuasion convincing all that stuff
none of that has
anything to do with science that has to
do with religion
anyone who does experiments is just
trying to convince you of something
they're trying to persuade you to try to
change your mind or to confirm
how you believe that's it it's got
nothing to do with
objectivity with understanding a
mechanism
which is what science and physics are
all about
again your fellow says
i think the same fellow says what says
bill is not a scientist
in the scientific method uh assumption
hypothesis investigation mechanism
conclusion
no mechanism or conclusion and no
mechanism in in all of
mathematical physics not not a rational
one for the invisible
intangible stuff okay mother nature's
invisible
intangible world there is no not one
mechanism not one okay but if you can
come up with
one mechanism hey great i'll buy you a
beer
okay uh retest assumption retest
for what what are you gonna retest it
for until we can falsify
the hypothesis well in in science we
don't falsify we don't do falsifications
that's uh
people who are trying to you know hit it
big
you know they falsify what documents
they falsify money
you know we don't falsify anybody in
science
physics and this fellow signs uh joe
sands i work
with atomic force microscope
i use my atomic force microscope i'm a
scientist he thinks he's a scientist
because he uses a microscope
[Laughter]
ah that's a lab boy he thinks he
sees himself as a scientist i'm a
deluded mathematician he says well yeah
that one i think he's he's probably
right okay i'll watch for that
yeah if to if to you science is about
describing verifying and falsifying
then yes i do not uh fit that
definition okay your definition of
science
uh and here's uh he continues with a
scientific method here
it says the essentials of science this
is according to him right the essentials
of science are evidence
okay what gathered in experiments what
do you need evidence for
evidence is used to persuade a jury
that's what you use evidence for
you don't use evidence in science you
use evidence
in religion anyone introducing evidence
is trying to persuade the jury
theories about the evidence theories
about the evidence no we need theories
about a mechanism
okay and then the requirement that
contradicting evidence
falsify a theory okay again a theory
means that they convinced you otherwise
that's all that
falsify means so we don't present
evidence we don't do experiment and we
don't falsify
uh theories explanations okay
whatever is false to you is true to your
neighbor so anyone using the word
falsify again
belongs to religion not the science okay
however it is gathered however it is
gathered evidence must be unambiguous
and repeatable
and it must be objective i like this he
said two impartial observers must come
to the same conclusion
okay what if they don't yeah what if
they don't come to the same conclusion
what should we do should we vote on in
uh 50
plus one wins or worse
what if they both agree and the two
observers came to the
conclusion that the world is flat
okay so we have the flat earthers or or
the two came to the conclusion that
jesus went to heaven and came back in
after three days or whatever
um what should we do should we
do the two observers agreed they're from
the same congregation
so again uh none of that has anything to
do with science it's got to do with
religion what this
fellow is talking about he thought he
was a scientist because he
runs in a microscope
my god poor fellow okay and uh
one fellow says what it says uh lac
creates lhc the large hadron collider in
cern geneva switzerland i've been there
it looks nice from the outside lhc
creates matter from colliding
light based on e equals m c squared
people are so gullible people are really
gullible
okay so uh uh what does he say says last
year the atlas experiment
at the lhc observed two photons
uh this came from i think from uh the
article that this file referenced
they observed you know observed like
with your eyesight they observed two
photons
just zipping by them two photons you
observe the photons
you know just going by see they use
these words observed
and people swallow that like candy you
know they say okay they observed it
who's gonna
who's gonna question that if they
observed it what do you mean they
observed how can they
observe two photons what do they mean by
observe
and that's what i'm gonna get into what
they mean by observe so that you see
what that word
means how they cheat with that word like
they cheat with the word pointing with
the word circle
here we have the word observed okay
let's see what observe means they
observe two photons particles of light
so they observe two particles of light
look at that they've got very good
eyesight
forget about you know superman i mean
his
uh x-ray vision you know comes out of
the eyes
goes through the walls ricocheting off
one another producing two new photons
so here they observed two photons
they collided ricocheted uh
one from the other and they turned into
uh into what um they tried
they discovered where is it uh and
producing two new photons okay so they
bouncing it to produce two new photons
let's see how they did this how did they
observe how did they prove this
all this evidence all these experiments
that belong to science right let's see
how they did all this stuff i
i want to know this year they've
discovered photons merging and
transforming into what
w bozos and particles that carry the
weak force there you see the poor
particle carrying the weak force okay
okay
what is this guy referring to so i look
up the article that he referenced
and let's go there let's find out what
this is all about
two photons and they turn them into two
more photons
and they observe the photons whizzing by
let's find out how they did all this i
i really want to know that i mean
science has advanced
beyond my ears okay so you go and you
find it here this is the article he
referenced it's uh the
magazine is known as symmetry it's run
by what fermilab
and slack what is slack stanford linear
accelerator
okay so these are big people you know
they receive government funds
that means your money you're paying for
this okay and
the article said a collision of light
a collision of light they're gonna
explain how light collided against light
uh what we call light on light okay okay
let's find out what these folks
did how they did their experiment how
they observed
a photon hitting another photon now i'm
going to go slowly here so that you get
the whole picture okay of
how they did this how they proved that a
photon
collided against another photon okay so
this is the starting point okay
keep track of this okay for most of the
year the lac collides
protons okay proton allegedly is a
little ball that's in the center of the
atom okay
fine but for about a month each fall the
lhc
switches things up and collides what
photons maybe they collide
heavy atomic nuclei such as
lead ions we're still talking about
protons in fact here we're talking about
protons and electrons
uh what they're saying is the ion that
the atom is ionized meaning that it lost
one of its outer electrons okay
but here they're going to collide what
first they collided
uh protons which are little balls in the
center
and now they're going to collide with
lead atoms
okay in other words they ionize and
that's what they're going to
accelerate and collide so far we have
nothing about photons
that's what that's the point i'm trying
to make here these ion runs
also enable scientists to turn the lhc
into what
a photon photon collider whoa
okay so far we don't know how they did
that all we have is a statement a
clean unjustified claim unsubstantiated
claim let's find out
this result demonstrates that photons
can scatter off
each other and change each other's
direction
that's what they're going to show with
this experiment
that all these photons are bouncing off
each other
because they're what they're what are
they accelerating
lead ions lead ions
okay that's so far that's all we have so
far so far they have justified the
so-called photon okay let's go to the
page number two
really it was in one article small
article
okay and so this is how they continue in
their
description when heavy nuclei are
accelerated in the lhc they are encased
within
an electromagnetic aura
generated by their large positive
charges
okay yeah whatever charges are as the
nuclei travel faster and faster their
surrounding fields are squished
into disks making them much
more concentrated okay so far again uh
we're talking about atoms and nuclei
okay we're talking about lead
uh nuclei in other words lead ions when
two lead ions pass closely enough that
they're electromagnetic
fields a concept right there you see at
the bottom
uh shoes through one another so we have
the fields now going through each other
whatever field is
never saw a field uh switch through
another one
okay they'd have to draw that so we know
what a field is
the high energy photons which ultimately
make up these fields can interact
so here we have a magnet right i would
show my
two little magnets there they are okay
and you can see that
they uh they stick to one another okay
so they're saying that what's in here is
photons that's the field
the magnetic field of of a uh atom
ion right is made of
photons that's what they're saying there
okay
that's how they're going to turn this
thing into you know colliding
photons they're going to collide fields
and the fields are made of photons
that's their argument okay in rare
instances a photon from one lead ion
will merge with a photon from it in
an uncoming lead ion and it will
ricochet
in different directions so now that we
turn the field which is made of photons
they say we've never seen a field made
of photons but this is what they say
and now they they simply state that the
these
uh so-called photons they bounce off
each other
okay how does this thing uh end
here it is find out how gullible these
people are that believe all this
nonsense
sorry i'm meant idiocy however according
to steinberg one of the fellows that
uh helped write this article again or
contributed
it's not as simple as two solid
particles bouncing off each other oh
it's not so it's not
particles which are not particles
anyways in mathematical physics
especially in quantum
light particles are both chartless and
massless
okay and must go through a quantum
mechanical
loophole to interact with one another
okay let's look at this loophole how do
they do this
they have no way to bounce off each
other without
help oh we need the servants now
we need to help okay when the two
photons see
each other inside the lhc they sometimes
overreact with excitement and split
themselves into an electron
and positron pair okay so now the two
photons turned
each one turned into an electron
position fair now we have four of these
four particles two electrons two
positrons right
these electron positron pairs are not
fully formed
entities okay but rather unstable
quantum fluctuations
there are fluctuate they're just
vibrations that scientists call what
virtual particles so now these particles
appeared where from the void you know
from nowhere
magical uh god made them
just for the purposes of the experiment
right the four virtual particles swirl
into each other and recombine to form
two new photons
which scatter off at weird angles into
the detector
what are they saying let's illustrate
this
so that you get the picture here's the
picture
of what these people are saying you can
later read it
more carefully here it is let's put it
on this side okay
so this is what they're saying you have
two photons they
collide because what is colliding are
really the fields and the fields are
made of photons according to these
people that means that
a magnet attracts another by throwing
photons
balls at each other's you know and these
positrons and electrons recombine
because uh they are virtual particles
that come in out of nowhere
they recombine they form the two photons
and each one of these photons and
just goes off into different directions
in the in
are captured by the detector so this
is how they said they proved
this is how they observed through
experiment you know
you've got to do it through experiment
this is how they observed and proved
through experiment
that photons collide the photons turn
into
virtual particles which recombine and
create photons again
great that's the theory that's their
explanation and that's their physical
interpretation and gullible people like
this
individual here you know he swallows
this like candies
he drinks the kool-aid like you would
believe
okay with that i'm gonna see you next
time on wednesday and hopefully we have
smarter people
ask questions and all these